China's economic rise has been Swift and
impressive and it seems a reasonable bet
that it will soon be it'll soon eclipsed
the US economy in the sense that it will
become the world's largest economy but
we still imagine even faced with that
challenge that Western ideas will
continue to dominate so one of the
questions we are asking today is is this
an illusion there are some contemporary
Chinese thinkers who argue that old
Chinese ideas such as
Tinch are all under heaven have a
greater potential to promote global
harmony than Western ideas of the
individual so is the Sun setting on
Western ideas as well as Western
economies or is Western thoughts are
still essential to growth and progress
including to Chinese growth and is it
already embedded in China's success do I
think the the idea that we're moving
from a situation where you know Western
hegemonies is a default it seems
undeniable I mean the populations are
shrinking for a start I think in the
Western European Western countries now
make up it's certainly less than 20
percent of the world's population I
think it may be as little as 10 or 15 or
something we've got other powers other
parts of the world which are growing in
economic might and where economic might
grows other kind of forms of soft power
tend to follow but then I don't really
want to sort of get into sucked into
this idea of you know is Chinese ideas
Western ideas as though they're sort of
this sort like competition which region
is going to grow I mean one thing that's
really clear is that the world is now
more interconnected than it ever was and
so the whole sort of notion of these
sort of hermetically sealed
cultures are you're competing to be
number one hopefully will become come
less relevant so I do think we'll see
more ideas coming out of not just China
but other other parts of the world a
little bit less than a West dominated
conversation here I don't think it's a
matter of you know China's inexorable
rise and you know to the in that kind of
almost zero sum game way of look
at it that's all for now gave me your
know to discern a belief and Western
individual believer in Western
individualism so so can you envisage
perhaps a more collective approach from
Chinese thinking what I think
well let me I think it will be useful to
just be a bit more definite about what
we're talking about here and I don't
open with you do you know I don't care
about really these Western ideas or not
but what are the ideas that are
associated with and they've partly
caused I think the great advances in the
west from the time of the Enlightenment
and the Industrial Revolution on I think
the the key ideas here are in the area
of inquiry it was a rejection of
authority so the idea that when you'd
want to know what the world's like you
there's no place for authority in that
area you can't it's not up for somebody
up to somebody to tell you what the
truth is you've got to find out the
truth through empirical methods and so
on and that's a big part of why we've
been so progressive in the West then in
the political sphere I think there are
really two notions two ideas that are
important and again I'm not saying these
are exclusively Western ideas but one is
equality and what I mean by equality
here is the that people are born equal
in the sense that they aren't there do
no legal privilege on account of their
birth and that was an important idea of
course not fully realized but
nonetheless it was a principle that we
adopted and it was used to criticize
ourselves and to make reforms the other
idea is the more that wanted with
individual liberty so people should be
free in various respects and we've got
some basic ideas about the freedoms due
to everybody freedom of association
freedom of expression in the economic
realm freedom of contract and freedom of
exchange and so on now these are the
ideas that I think are very closely
associated with the progress made in the
West over over recent centuries now
China has made a lot of economic
progress recently and it's done it by
adopting some of these ideas in the
economic sphere so they've moved from a
centrally planned economy to something
much more like a market economy in which
you
have some of these economic freedoms
that we've heard in the West for a long
time and that there's been a lot of
growth on the back of that so they've
adopted modern technologies and they've
entered into global trade and they've
made an enormous amount of progress
they haven't adopted the whole package
though they haven't got all these what
you might call civil or social or
personal liberties are enshrined the way
we do freedom Association expression so
on and there's a big question which I
don't presume to know the answer to of
whether or not their progress will
continue whether they come what you
might call the catch-up progress have
made will they be able to continue at
this rate without those other liberties
that we have and I know some scholars
who work on this and most of them say
that they think they're skeptical but I
don't presume to know now to get to the
final point will the progress that China
has made mean that we start thinking
okay their way of doing things might be
better their ideas might be better well
partly because the progress they've made
has been by adopting elements of our
thinking I I don't I don't think so
but I do think that West these ideas
that I've been talking about are on the
decline in the West I think our
commitment to them is eroding but it's
for its for reasons internal to us so
the idea a lot of people now believe
that these principles that I've
discussed are really just a license for
the strong in society to push around the
weak and like in an employment contract
freedom of contract unemployment that's
just a license from the employer to give
the employee a bad deal freedom
expression is just a license for the
dominant cultural views to be abusive
towards people who need to be protected
and so on so these ideas are on the rise
and they're they're banging up against
the general principles that I espoused
and it's an interesting question about
whether them as these principles a fade
a little or ameliorated turned down how
we want to put it will the West continue
to be as progressive as it has been and
I will we'll have to wait and see
Hey thank you
well will China's influence on the
thought match its meteoric rise
economically not here in the West I'm I
would agree I think with the other other
speakers on that and there are some
different reasons for that I mean the
note of panic on the one hand and
abiding superiority on the other that
are embedded in the questions that we've
been given to talk about today I think
we don't really need to take either of
those as seriously as the what tone in
which they're posed is economic success
is easy to show and we have agreed-upon
measures for it and the Chinese well
it's success while it hasn't been in the
rather heavily freighted adjective that
was used in the in the blurb for this
discussion it hasn't been relentless
they've actually had some ups and downs
and and some disasters and and mixed
results nonetheless it it has been
something that we cannot possibly fail
to see it has implications for everyone
around the globe and so it's been taken
notice of Chinese ideas however or what
cultural or philosophical or moral and
ethical superiority would look like or
success or a progress that we don't
agree on around the world as as easily
and so I think it's going to be very
difficult to for the Chinese to make
claims that are are can be held up and
and and defended that what they have to
offer to the world is really superior in
some way better
anyway cultural and ideational change is
something that happens more slowly then
certainly the kind of economic change
we've seen in the last couple of decades
in in China so if China's rise has been
relentless the economic rise and this is
my third reason for thinking that the
West is not about to be inundated with a
second
a victorious rise of Chinese thinking so
too has a relentless has been the drone
of hostile attitudes expressed toward
the tornados warnings in the West
continually especially since the rise of
the Communist Party some seventy years
ago now that what China's thought is is
is dangerous that a most ordinary folks
that I meet who are not students as an
academic who are well-meaning
right-thinking people they they think
they know what Chinese thought it has to
offer I don't know whether they think
they learned it from reading newspapers
or watching documentaries on television
or seeing dramatizations in cinema or
reading memoirs of Chinese who were who
had a very bad time in their own culture
but they think they know what Chinese
thought leads to and they don't like it
and so I think we're going to hear a lot
of opposition in the West to any
pretension on the part of the Chinese
that they have answers in the moral and
ethical and philosophical realm that we
should we should grasp that's why I
think the much more interesting sphere
over which to consider this question
about the rise in Chinese thought is in
the non West to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a IDOT
TV for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas